la philharmonie c'est lui le musée du
quai branly lui aussi le louvre abou
dhabi encore lui
un seul homme derrière ces réalisations
très variés l'architecte jean nouvel
je ne pense pas qu'il puisse y avoir une
unité stylistique lié à un architecte je
pense pas qu'un architecte qui
s'approprie un style comme un artiste et
dire ou que je sois je fais partout la
même chose
jean nouvelle n'a pas de marque de
fabrique qu'il n'en cherche pas c'est
justement ce qui lui a valu la
reconnaissance de ses pairs à
l'international en 2008 il a reçu le
prix pritzker l'équivalent du nobel en
architecture et ils disent que je suis
quelqu'un qui prend des risques
je suis quelqu'un qui qui étend le champ
de le chambre de l' architecture et qui
travaillent sur des situations à chaque
fois différentes et spécifiez plutôt que
de créer un style et une continuité dans
son travail
jean nouvel adapte ses projets à
l'environnement qui les accueillent à
leurs occupants tout en étant le reflet
de l'époque
c'est ce qui l'expliqué en 1994 sur le
plateau du cercle de minuit
il faut qu'on joue avec d'autres
éléments qui sont de plus en plus la
matière de la situation sur la lumière
ça nous sort de l'académisme et des
recettes il y avait des recettes
d'architecturé comme il ya des recettes
de cuisine c'est fini maintenant à
chaque fois il faut réfléchir en france
jean nouvel a bâti sa renommée en
concevant la fondation cartier en 1994
l'institut du monde arabe en 1987 il est
aussi l'un des rares à avoir exporté
larchitecture française
la tour agbar à barcelone en 2005 ou
plus récemment le musée du louvre abou
dhabi
le soleil qui tape à travers donne ses
impacts de lumière sur les bâtiments sur
le sol et sur l'eau qui sont toujours
différents toutes les réalisations de
jean nouvelles ne sont pas pour autant
des réussites la philharmonie de paris
par exemple a été en partie ratée du
propre aveu de l'architecte
on se retrouve dedans avec des moquettes
absolument ridicule avec des avec des
lieux de transition entre le vert
le bois est
le plâtre qui sont accepteriez pas dans
votre maison de campagne à paris en
france et ailleurs
l'atelier de jean nouvel compte une
cinquantaine de projets en cours
toujours avec cette volonté de se battre
contre une architecture lycée près
pensée est parachuté partout sur la
planète
[Musique]